let's say Pete over here thinks that
he's a pretty good investor so what he
does is or he has an idea that says look
I'm going to create a corporation and
I'm going to get a bunch of people to
contribute money to that corporation and
then I'll manage that money and maybe
I'll take a little fee for myself so
that I can maybe hire some analysts or
get some computers or some get some
office space so what he does is he sets
up a corporation let's say he sets up a
corporation right over here and let's
say the way with the way he first sets
up the corporation let's say it just has
four shares and I'm making the number
really small just to make the drawing in
the math easy
this wouldn't be realistic normally it
would be something in the hundreds or
thousands of shares or maybe even more
than that but let's say it has four
shares and let's say all of the four
shares are owned by Pete initially just
to simplify the explanation and he puts
in $400 $400 into this corporation so
another way to think about it in
exchange for him putting $400 into this
corporation he gets four shares or each
share each share is worth is worth $100
each of these shares right over here and
so what he does is he registers this
corporation and I'm talking about a US
specific case but there's similar types
of organizations in other countries he
registers this organization right over
here with the US SEC Securities and
Exchange Commission and he also
registers himself with the SEC or even
better he registers a management company
that he runs with the SEC so let's call
it Pete Pete Inc is a corporation he
starts off that he also registers with
the SEC and when he registers with the
SEC he tells them that look this company
right over here we're going to issue
more shares for more people to
contribute money and I'm going to manage
this money right over here and I'm just
going to take a percentage of the total
assets under management sometimes you'll
see AUM use that just means assets under
management that will go to Pete Inc
every year for figuring out the best
place to invest this money and it's
usually on the order of about one
percent sometimes a little bit less
sometimes a little bit more so one
percent per year so right now with only
$400 assets for
hundred dollars under management it
would only be about $4 per year but
since he registered with the SEC he can
call himself a mutual fund and he can
solicit funds from the public so it is a
mutual fund he has met he's jumped
through all the hoops that the SEC sets
up for him so he can market he can
market himself as some type of great
fund manager we don't know if that's
true or not and he can also solicit
funds from the public so from from the
public and we're going to see in future
videos there are other funds especially
hedge funds that can't just that one
they can't market and they can't take
funds from the public those can only
take funds from certain types of
sophisticated investors and what happens
in Pete's fund and this is going to be
an open-ended mutual fund that we're
showing here and most mutual funds are
like that let's say that Sal comes along
he likes Pete's marketing materials I
said hey I want to I want Pete to manage
my money too so Sal goes and he gives
$100 and he and says Pete give me a
share so Pete creates another share
right over here he creates another share
he gives it to Sal so he gets one share
that's me I get one share and then
exchange I gave $100 to the fund so now
the fund has the fund has $500 so this
is another hundred dollars right over
here and now Pete's annual fee is going
to be one percent of this whole thing or
five dollars a year and if this whole
thing grows let's say this whole thing
doubles to from $500 let's see it
doubles to $1,000 then that thousand
dollars is essentially split amongst
these five shares now so all of the
people will essentially have their money
doubled - whatever Pete's expenses are
in the next few videos I'll go over a
little bit more of the mechanics of an
open-ended mutual fund